Hey guys, this is Aaron. I want to take a
look today at installing extensions. There's
a couple of different ways to get extensions
installed in SketchUp. The first one we will
look at is via the Extension Warehouse. If
I click on the Extension Warehouse button
or go to window, Extension Warehouse, it will
pull up this browser window of the Extension
Warehouse. Now, from here you can use the
search box or the extension list or filters
to find the extension you want. In my case
I am going to go find one of the ThomThom
extensions. And I'm going to scroll down.
What I'm looking for is Groups to Components.
Now the first thing you want to make sure
you are doing is logging into Extension Warehouse.
There are a couple of reasons you want to
do this. One is if you download it, the extension
you download will go into your "My Extensions"
list so in future versions, or if you install
into a new computer, it's really easy to just
go to "My Extensions" and install all of your
extensions at once. The other reason I would
do this is because instead of download I will
actually get the install button. To install
this Groups to Components extension, all I
have to do is click the install button. It's
going to come up and prompt me reminding me
that I am giving this program some rights
on my computer. Do you want to install? I'm
going to hit yes, and I'm done. Okay, so if
I come out here now, I'll find that if I go
to extension, I have the option of Convert
Groups to Components. That extension is now
installed. Now, when it comes to maintaining
those installed extensions, I can click this
button right here to get my extension manager
up. The extension manager is going to give
you a list of all the extensions that are
installed in this copy of SketchUp, including
the one I just installed right here - Groups
to Components. Now, if I want to, from this
screen, I can actually disable individual
extensions. So, if I don't want to see Groups
to Components I can temporarily, without uninstalling
it, disable it by clicking the enable/disable
switch and hitting apply changes. If I want
to permanently disable or remove, I can uninstall
by using the manage tab. The other thing that
is nice about the manage tab is if you have
an update to one of your extensions, you will
actually have the ability to click the update
button and update that. Now the update button
is only going to show up for extensions that
are installed through the Extension Warehouse.
Speaking of which, if I wanted to install
an extension that I didn't find in the Extension
Warehouse, I can do that through the extension
manager by clicking install extension, navigating
to where that RBZ file is. in this case I
have Eneroth's Camera Memory. I'm going to
click on that. I'm going to hit open, and,
with that, it is installed. So I have that
right here. Again, easy to install, and at
this point it is just like an extension that
was installed through the warehouse, except
that it won't be available for updates. So,
there you go! That is how you go about installing
and managing your extensions inside of SketchUp.
Thank you.